[Applause]
now this is how the internet's daddy
makes an entrance Pedro Pascal and
Valentino short shorts and combat boots
sort of gave us Angelina Jolie Vibes ET
just confirmed Pedro is in final talks
to Star and Paramount's highly
anticipated Gladiator sequel alongside
Denzel Washington and Paul Mesko Pedro
congratulations on Gladiator
yes from maluma to simulio to key Creek
one in fingerless glove hi
the men served up the looks at the Met
Gala
Bradley Cooper went with a black tux and
aviators inside he met up with Irina
shaykh proving they might be the
friendliest Exes in Hollywood guess
who's back
and I had a sweet little reunion of my
own with Dr Dre you and me
pepper
how are you good to see trust me
this is my first time here it's exciting
and I know I'm gonna hear and see
something that's extremely inspiring but
did you reach out to maybe friends like
Beyonce or Rihanna Jimmy Iving that's
what I reached out what kind of tips did
he give you about coming to the mecca
just have fun that's it
foreign